what I want to do in this video is
really make some clarifications and go a
little bit more in detail about the
different layers of the earth so let me
draw let me draw a cross-section of the
earth over here and I'll try to do it I
won't be able to do it perfectly to
scale but I'll try to do a little bit
better job and giving you a little bit
of a sense of how thick these layers are
so let's say that this is the crust up
here and I'm going to make the
continental crust a little bit thicker
so let's say that that is continental
crust and this is continental crust and
then in between let me put some oceanic
crust which is going to be thinner so
this right here is actually in a
different color let me do the oceanic
crust in blue but this isn't water this
is rock I'll do it in purple that's even
better
I don't want to be that thick so let me
draw the oceanic crust is thinner than
the continental crust which I'm trying
to depict right over here so this right
over here is oceanic oceanic crust and
up here is continental crust continental
continental crust and the thickness or
how deep you can go and still be in
crust it depends on where you are and we
know that near hot spots the oceanic
crust can actually thin out a good bit
but roughly when we talk about the crust
we're talking about something that's
thirty to sixty kilometers deep so
thirty to sixty kilometers deep so if
you are on a continent which I'm
assuming you are and you dig for twenty
kilometers you will still be in the
crust 30 kilometers probably still in
the crust
if you dig for 70 kilometers or 100
kilometers you will probably reach the
mantle and remember what we're
describing here when we talk about the
crust the mantle and the core we're
talking about the chemical makeup let me
make this clear we're talking about the
chemical makeup the chemical makeup the
crust is fundamentally different than
the mantle based on the molecules that
it is made up of made based on its
composition so let's talk about the
mantle now so the mantle layer like this
and once again this is not to scale
because the
rust we're talking about thirty to sixty
kilometers the mantle we're talking
about on the order of about 2900 or
3,000 kilometers thick so this right
here is the entire mantle so that's the
mantle and this is 2900 to 3000 3000
kilometers thick so this isn't even one
thirtieth of that so I would have to
draw it even narrower than the way I've
drawn it over here and the mantle itself
can be subdivided into the upper mantle
and the lower mantle so let me draw this
division we draw this division right
over here the upper mantle and there's
different ways to define the boundary
but you could the upper mantle is
roughly about 700 kilometers down so
these are huge distances I mean this is
going straight down so this is the upper
mantle let me write it on the actual
mantle here this is the upper mantle and
this over here is the lower the lower
mantle and just to be clear on things so
the crust is solid now when you go into
the upper mantle the upper part of the
up upper mantle and we'll talk about
that a little bit more is cool enough to
be solid so there is a solid portion
there is a solid portion of the upper
mantle so all of this up here is solid
because it's cool enough it hasn't
reached the melting point of of those of
those rocks just yet and we learned in
previous videos that the combination of
the solid part the solid part of the
upper mantle and the crust combined we
call that the lithosphere and we talked
about the lithosphere we're not talking
about the mechanical make up we're not
talking about what's solid and what's
not solid so this is the lithosphere
this is the lithosphere you go a little
bit deeper right below the lithosphere
now the temperatures are high enough for
and I use the word liquid but that's not
exactly right you can kind of think of
it as kind of a deformable solid or a
plastic solid or a magma and that's the
asthenosphere so this area right over
here this layer area right over here the
liquid part actually I shouldn't use the
word liquid kind of define
formable it deforms over long periods of
time but it is it is it is more fluid
than what we normally associate with
rock magma would be a good way to think
about it that's what we call the
asthenosphere it is fluid just not as
fluid as water it is more viscous than
something like water so this is the
asthenosphere a stano's sphere now the
upper mantle is able it's hot enough for
the the rock to melt and be fluid and
the pressure is low enough for two not
four to still be able to kind of move
past it itself to still to have a to be
somewhat fluid but then once you get
even deeper into the lower mantle into
the lower mantle you even hot you have
higher pressure higher pressure and so
it has actually it's still fluid but
it's less fluid it's less it's it's it's
kind of thicker I guess it's the best
way to think about it in the lower
mantle it's thicker so this whole area
over here you could kind of think of it
as melted rock it's it's fluid but the
upper part of the melted rock can it's
more fluid it's able to move easier
because there's less pressure and the
pressures just from all of the rock
that's above it remember gravity is
pulling down on everything gravity every
every molecule here wants to go downward
because of gravity so it's applying
pressure downwards so the deeper you go
the more pressure you get now when we
get even deeper than that we get to the
core and the core is divided between the
outer core and the inner core so the our
outer core outer core outer core and
then of course you have the inner core
the inner inner core and just so we have
a sense for distances the width or the
thickness of the outer core is
approximately 2,300 kilometers so these
are huge distances when you think about
thickness you could go down another 2300
kilometers and you're in the or once you
go through the mantle you can go 2,300
kilometers through the outer core and
then you're in the inner core and that
essentially takes you the rest that's
essentially the center of the earth and
the inner core and maybe I should draw
it maybe I should draw the boundaries a
little bit more to scale let me do it
this way it should actually look a
little bit more
like a little bit a little bit more like
this because the outer core is thicker
than the inner core so the outer core is
as I said let me write rewrite it outer
core is on the order it's about 2,300
kilometers thick and then you have your
inner core you have your I shouldn't do
it in blue I should do it in the hot
color so the inner core right over here
is just kind of takes us to the center
of the earth and that's a little over a
color that's over a little over a
thousand kilometers thick so this is the
inner core inner core the number I have
is about 1,200 1,200 kilometers thick
and both the the entire core when you
both the outer core and the inner core
is mainly nickel and iron and think
about when the earth was forming what
happens is when this whole earth was
super hot and it was kind of in a fluid
state the heavier elements were allowed
to the heavier elements were allowed to
sink down when everything was fluid the
things that are in between would kind of
were the things that were lighter would
go up and then the gaseous things that
would naturally be in the gaseous state
would kind of bubble up would kind of
bubble up through that fluid you know
kind of the way the way actually you
know carbon bubbles up in a soda it
would eventually bubble out of the fluid
and it would actually form the
atmosphere so that's why when you look
at the composition of the earth you have
the densest the heaviest elements in the
center and then the lightest elements
are forming the atmosphere and the outer
core in the inner core they are made up
predominantly of nickel and iron nickel
and iron and their makeup is actually
very similar so this division chemically
they are they have a very similar
composition what's different about them
is at the outer core you have
temperatures high enough that nickel and
iron can melt but the pressures are low
enough that they can still be in a fluid
state so this is our liquid this is our
liquid outer core and this has a pretty
low viscosity especially even relative
to the mantle so that's why people kind
of consider this in kind of a more
traditional liquid state but as you get
deeper and deeper and deeper the
pressure becomes so huge as you get to
the inner core remember all of the
weight of every of all of the rock above
you have these thousands of miles
of rock above you is all pushing down on
the rock below it so the inner core even
though the temperature is really really
really hot the pressure is so big that
the molecules can't flow past each other
they can't be liquid they're kind of
jammed packed and so the inner core
because of the high pressure despite the
high temperature is solid it's solid so
the difference here is actually a
mechanical one between the outer core
and the inner core they're made up of
the same things roughly the same
chemical makeup it's just slightly lower
lower pressure on the outside so you can
actually be in a fluid state so
hopefully that clarifies and gives you a
little bit of depth on on the makeup of
the earth